[Music]
in love package news love package with a
gun submitted by [ __ ] stinky Pete and
Idaho boy pack the Christmas package for
a stranger overseas years later they met
and got married what was in that package
Tiffani condoms dildos new diamonds
you're the boy Oh
condoms what was in the package but I'll
tell you their love story it's really
cute okay
well this is kind of one of those love
stories you're complaining about earlier
how you're like you don't care about
yeah you don't let's hear this one for
Barry alright stop it Tyrell
seven-year-old Tyrell back in 2000 he
participated in this program called
Operation Christmas Child
and that's when there's churches and
organizations that from all over the
nation that they partner up with
Samaritan's Purse to send out toys or
school supplies or I did it
you're so giving anything that can fit
into a shoebox yes oh they'll those
Sandi shoeboxes out to over 150
countries and so they're saying that
since 1993 this organization has
collected and delivered more than 135
million gift filled shoeboxes so taro
was one of these kids that sent out a
shoebox and it ended up with Johanna in
the Philippines and she came she became
his mail-order bride yeah yeah girls
will never understand what this is like
but imagine if you are a guy that is not
that desirable and you gave away this
gift when you're a very young boy not
knowing that it would be given to a
really really hot girl and you grow up
and you're ugly as [ __ ] and you can't
take anybody to the prom and then nobody
will [ __ ] you and all of a sudden the
hottest girl from the Philippines comes
over and she wants to bone because she
remembers how sweet you are how you know
she's hot I just like to imagine
mr. imagination might as well just go
all the way with it right he's like the
saddest boy and she's the hottest girl
yeah
she has no accent perfect she makes the
best pancit ever yeah almost ten years
later in 2009 Tyrell received a facebook
friend request
Robbie Lannister young girl in the
Philippines but he wasn't familiar with
her so he's just ignored it and two
years after that she sent him another
friend request because she wanted to
thank him for that box because she said
I was life-changing for her and her
family like what he gave oh okay because
he Christmas it was a Christmas thing
the Christmas presents could have been
like a bag of barbeque blaze was a bunch
of stuff he'll put animals what we did
was like a crap kind of like school
supplies stationaries oh [ __ ] I would I
would hate you doing [ __ ] and I just
gave them pencils if I if I was freaking
poor kid and I got a box of school
supplies I was honest dude [ __ ] you
David [ __ ] here that's like when you got
clothes for Christmas dude that's like
oh no thanks you know what they told us
was that they loved it though but then
we would get like personal letters back
from them yeah and then were they
colored pencils mine no they were that
green and yellow one Frank
I was poor it was a poor kid
yeah but Joanna she tried sending Tara a
thank-you letter as well just like what
David was saying but apparently he got
lost in the mail he never got it and so
that's why she was still she still
wanted to thank him after all those
years because he in that shoebox he put
to be white because his name was Tyrell
oh wow she probably found Allah wait
does he have a [ __ ] rat tail no it's
like a feather
okay I was like this can't have a
braided rat tail that goes halfway down
his back no it's like it's like it's
like a rope well it looks like it's part
of his
I don't know yeah you'd like a cowboy in
this photo I really like that shirt
though it's like a flag like a brown
rainbow oh yeah that's like that's
that's one of the flags looks like you
got it and maybe Tyrell is Jonah when
she received her gift and so she just
really wanted to thank him and then
since he wrote his name on the back of
the photo that's why years later she
thought about him and she looked for him
on Facebook so then that second time
that he requested him he asked her like
who are you like how do we know each
other or whatever you gave me pencils
some [ __ ] this is a real story wait
so he gave her pencils and she was
trying to track his ass down because he
had the new brass picture David keeps
David keeps winning pencils in the box
we don't know what was it the bus what
could have been so cool all right David
you put that in my new inception that
[ __ ] a little bit she can't work it was
actually pens oh I love pens though yeah
it was a gel pen it was a good idea
racers a [ __ ] like that too in there oh
that would have been my Hello Kitty
thongs for a whole year and then finally
he saved up money to go visit her and he
spent a week or 10 days there how hot is
she now yeah it's gotta be nice right
now even though to the Philippines were
pretty cheap yeah if you're not doing
business class yeah okay maybe she
doesn't have to be that smoking anymore
though that was in May of 2013 when he
went to visit her the first time he went
again for the second time in November
and of the same year and then that's
when he asked for her hand in marriage
but I don't ask for cash she didn't even
have to like try to get tonight I'm
Filipino and you look like that kid that
could be us I've had kids a good
it's your guys's story what is the prize
no more shirts like that dude he gave me
a shoebox little Christmas present when
I was really poor and add a ruffs gifts
card in it it's true show us the
pictures that I got to see what they
both I'm not showing you the pictures I
wanna see the pictures
oh my god alright what happened they
both got AIDS they got married in his a
family ranch in Idaho and they currently
live in that same area and they also
have a little baby boy so she left the
Philippines
yeah she or she did I wonder why yeah
come on yeah she got married moved to
America
this is when they got married oh I like
his shirt now I big participate every
single year in the same program and they
give shoeboxes they're pretty looks like
that guy from botanic what a nice story
that's cute I love that when he was a
kid he dressed more like a businessman
than right now look like a young
professional you know that's what my mom
did to she dressed us up in like [ __ ]
coals we're yeah yeah yeah look like she
got a gift certificate to Kohl's and
then she would dress me up like a little
businessman like the only thing I was
missing was like a cell phone clip on my
freakin belt
dude but one time he said that about a
picture we were looking at like this
little picture of him as a kid and he
had the same outfit in his closet
there's everything adult for you say
wear clothes you gotta show a lot of
legs all the time yeah you take my pants
off what no I don't like you're married
to I tell you to cover up he hides all
my pants what I don't like we do you
have no idea you have no clicking San
moonstones and oh dude in MacArthur Park
no but tell them the time that's where
it's weird
you [ __ ] exactly no but yeah I
thought this is pretty cool there's
three out feet you know he sends this
shoebox and it actually you brought them
together and they're like really
religious and they're like God brought
us together that see that now that
starts to yes because they use magic
when you use magic the love is real I
just think it's pathetic we're talking
about this not the hurricane guys not
being all bummed out guys right don't
you love that people always like no
matter what you talked about before like
well there's people hurting somewhere so
I hope you guys are always gonna bring
down the me exactly it is it's like well
geez can we just have fun with one what
disaster it was but it was a terrible
one and you know like a couple days have
passed and I just tweeted something
random too like well thanks for not
worrying about whatever the hurricane or
whatever I just wrote back to him I was
like you're a [ __ ] loser die that's
like if you if you posted some ice cream
on the dress and swirls Instagram and
someone's like well thanks for [ __ ]
worrying about the victims of Harvey
yeah thanks to me that I don't need
didn't even know what's happening in the
world cuz I don't really like to turn on
the news and makes me really sad and
makes me feel really help helpless and
and though they'll say something like
that like glad to see you care about
such and such thing and I was like I
didn't even know that was happening you
don't even care what the Wildfire I'd
have to know about it to care I think
the worst in media to think I don't care
about is if I heard that so I was like
nah I'm gonna tweet about kittens yeah
it's like no I just want to take a
pictures of super dope burrito I'm about
to eat right exactly yeah way to use
your [ __ ] voice of influence to just
talk about how you [ __ ] today seriously
how much personal news my uncle died of
AIDS
so yeah that's true by the way so well
hey you guys want to stock any of us
we'll go ahead down to the description
box below and you can follow us on
Instagram and all kinds of stuff for
more videos
[Music]
[Music]